PROFESSOR: We can get to
documentation for the MATLAB
ODE Suite by entering
this command at the MATLAB
prompt-- doc ode45.
This will bring us to an
extensive documentation
for MATLAB ode45 that
includes among other things
this chart that compares
MATLAB ODE solvers.
There are seven of
them and this compares
their various attributes.
As we've said before, MATLAB
ode45 is the workhorse.
It's a nonstiff solver
with medium accuracy
that is the first
one you should try,
and we use it most of the time.
I have a soft heart in my
heart for MATLAB ode23.
It's a nonstiff solver
with low accuracy,
but its accuracy
that's appropriate
for graphics work because
the step size it chooses
is appropriate for
most graphics work.
MATLAB ode113 we haven't
talked about it yet,
there could be a comma
between the 1 and the 13
here because this
is a variable order
method where the order varies
all the way from 1 to 13.
It's a multi-step method
that saves history.
If, you know about these things,
it's an Adams-Moulton method.
I associate this with worked
done at Jet Propulsion
Laboratory years ago for
computing orbits of planets
and satellites, which of
course are very smooth
and go on for years.
It can have very high
accuracy requirements.
Then there are
the stiff solvers.
There are four of them--
15s, 23s, and the twins,
the trapezoid rules.
15s is the primary stiff
solver, low to medium accuracy.
If you find ode45
is slow, taking
lots of steps-- indication that
the problem is stiff-- try 15s.
23s can be as a low order
method, low accuracy,
and used at crude
error tolerances.
We haven't talked
about mass matrices.
This is where there's
a matrix in front
of the derivative term, and this
can be used with constant mass
matrices.
And then the two routines
with T's in their name
are based on the
trapezoidal rule,
and they're for
use with problems
without any numerical damping.
You can see the documentation
for more details
on the trapezoid methods.
That's the MATLAB ODE
Suite seven solvers,
three for nonstiff problems
and four for stiff problems.
You may well get through
with never using anything
but ode45 may well
serve all your needs.
There's a second chart
in the documentation that
summarizes all the options that
are available through the ODE
Set function.
We've briefly mentioned the
tolerances, RelTol and AbsTol--
the output function-- these
are available in all seven
of the solvers.
There are various
other functions--
various other options--
available for more
specialized work,
including event handling,
providing a Jacobian
to the stiff solvers
so they don't have
to work so hard
taking numerical
differences, options
associated with
the mass matrices,
providing a limit
on the step size.
These are all our
options that can
be specified through ode Set
for more specialized work
with the ODE solvers.